no man's sky released today on ps4 and
one of the biggest questions still
unanswered is how its mysterious
multiplayer functionality works two
players have already managed to dispel a
little of that mystery though as they
managed to find the same planet and
attempted to meet up my name is Alex
Newhouse and if you were hoping you can
meet up with a buddy and no man sky I
have some bad news too as reported by
Kotaku the players who go by the sad
cactus and Seto Kat could not see each
other even though they coordinated to
make sure they were in the same place
this all began when the sad cactus
stumbled across a world already
discovered by setoka
the sad cactus then messaged the planets
Discoverer attempting to coordinate so
that they could test out no man Sky's
multiplayer they made it to the same
place even standing outside the same
settlement and while the world appeared
identical they never caught sight of one
another however the discovery mechanics
do work
one player found a plant and his name
appeared on the other players screen
when the plant was inspected this seems
to reiterate what developer hello Games
has stated over the past few days Sean
Murray recently tweeted that no man sky
is definitely not a multiplayer game and
he said before that it's extremely
unlikely that you'll ever see someone
else in addition the fact that you can
pause the game suggests that players are
in their own instances and no man Sky's
servers however Sean Murray's been
hinting today on Twitter that the game
servers are under strain so it's still
unclear whether or not it'll eventually
ever be possible to see someone else for
more on no man's sky including beginners
guides and tons of gameplay jet over to
GameSpot calm
you